con nuevas reglas llega al esperado
último debate los micrófonos de
presidente dan 8 amp y del candidato
demócrata joe biden serán silenciados
mientras el rival entrega los primeros 2
minutos de respuesta en cada uno de los
temas y es que esta vez los
estadounidenses esperan que los
aspirantes a la casa blanca y entreguen
propuestas concretas sobre 6 ejes el
kobe 19 la familia estadounidense la
carrera política el cambio climático la
seguridad nacional y el liderazgo
creo que silenciar los micrófonos es
injusto y también creo que está mal que
no se aborden las relaciones exteriores
y también creo que la presentadora de
sesgada
el cambio llega tras el caos del primer
encuentro marcado por las interrupciones
y las agresiones
además después de que el segundo debate
que estaba previsto para el 15 de
octubre fuera cancelado tras un
desacuerdo entre los candidatos sobre el
formato del mismo ya que la comisión de
debates presidenciales
la organización no partidista que está a
cargo de los encuentros desde 1988
proponía que se realizará de manera
virtual tras el diagnóstico positivo por
kobe 19 del presidente de donaldson con
lo que el mandatario no estuvo de
acuerdo en esta carrera contrareloj
expertos creen que trump interrumpiría -
y bailén hablará más para lo que estuvo
preparándose toda la semana y dejó en
manos de su candidata a la
vicepresidencia
kamala harris y del ex presidente barack
obama sus actos de campaña
el no ha mostrado ningún interés en
hacer un buen trabajo ni ayudar a las
personas
sólo a sí mismo de sus amigos está
usando la presidencia con un reality
show para obtener atención el debate
será moderado por la presentadora de la
cadena en risk y kristen walker y tendrá
lugar en la universidad de belmont en
nashville tennessee